[Music]
vladimir putin's annual press conference
the media socially distanced with three
pcr tests behind them
the big man himself with an entrance
worthy of a blockbuster far removed on
the stage
this is a chance for mostly russian
media to ask their questions on
everything from the big picture to the
very local but despite russia's massive
troop build up on its border with
ukraine its president insisted to me he
was not threatening anyone
you have said talked a lot about
security guarantees and now we've seen
your proposals you also say you have no
intention of invading ukraine so will
you guarantee unconditionally that you
will not invade ukraine or any other
sovereign country or does that depend on
how negotiations go
uh
our actions will not depend on the
course of the negotiations but on the
unconditional compliance with russia's
security today and from a historical
perspective in this context we've made
it clear that nato's further eastward
expansion is unacceptable
i've said this many times and you
probably know this well not a single
inch to the east nato guaranteed us that
in the 1990s and you know what they
cheated us five waves of nato expansion
and there you go they're now in romania
and poland with weapon systems this is
what we're talking about it's not about
us threatening someone have we come to
the borders of the us or the uk maybe no
they came to our borders
you should not demand guarantees from us
you must give us the guarantees it's up
to you and you must do this immediately
right now
not quite right now but talks on
security are set to begin early next
year the west likely to try and buy time
russia insisting they don't drag on both
sides mired in deep mutual distrust
what is it do you think that the west
does not understand about russia or
about your intentions
sometimes it looks to me that we live in
two different worlds back in the 1990s
the ussr did everything it could to
build normal relations with the west
with the united states
you could have perhaps treated russia as
a potential ally and strengthened trust
but no instead you tried to keep
breaking us up this session was a way of
landing the message back home that
russia here is the aggrieved party
fighting off external aggressors a
question of selective memory from a keen
but distinctly amateur historian and
certainly no guarantees of peace in our
time
diana magnay sky news moscow